uh kyle you've been on the arena i think
that
i've always appreciated your words about
this as
all of these crimes have come to light
what has been your reaction about the
response and what we're seeing in
america right now
well i think like everything else these
are important conversations for us to be
having i think asian americans have
mostly felt unseen
for a really long time these crimes that
we're
seeing now many of us for the first time
they've been happening for a long time i
was recently talking to
a friend of mine who's who's a korean
and i
in you know in a age right now in a year
we talk so much about white and black
and brown
i'm like do you do you feel like you fit
into one of those categories and he said
he said no
like literally asian americans do not
feel seen their problems do not feel
seen
but they're a significant part of our
country 23 million people
um and it's like 20 percent of our
uh medical force uh 50
of silicon valley is asian americans
like this these are these are people who
are deciding a lot of things in
in our country right now and and they're
you know for us to just keep on ignoring
them um
this is this is another issue that we
have to tackle that we have to be more
aware of and then we have to have more
conversations about
i um a few weeks ago on my social media
i put up a post and i had some words and
and i joined to stop asian hate hashtag
and i started thinking about that and i
started thinking about
how many people did i know that have
real relationships
with people in the asian community i do
you know i i think of mr lee ning i
think of mr hong
i think of felix i think of joey
you know i think a crawl i think of
these people who i know personally
and i know they're families personally
and to me
this is about right versus wrong
and it's wrong to target
our fellow asian brothers and sisters
it's wrong to target them with jokes
it's wrong to target them with with
anything that can hurt and harm
them um it's about standing up for
what's right
and what's right is making sure that
racist joke racist jokes and racist
dialogues it's not
it's not something that you allow in
your space
right and so it's not enough just to put
a post up
we have to step in we have to say
something
and you know i wrote this right here
and i want to say this and
in this world we live in if you don't
know someone
then you feel like that's not my fight
because i don't know them
well to me
our fight in this world is about safety
it's about peace
and it's the instability to want to live
life without
fear right that's that's all we want we
want safety peace we want to live life
without fear
and so that should be all of our fight
it shouldn't just be the asian-american
community fight
it should be all about fight and it's
time for us to continue to use our
platforms
and our voices to speak up and speak out
and do something about it
if you're looking for a place to donate
as well aajc
uh